[Music]
elon
let's just start right with uh where
where john
john posed the question i mean you've
spoken often in your career
about how important it was for you as a
young entrepreneur an innovator to come
to america and you've said
there's no other country where you could
have achieved what you've achieved today
definitely
when you look at the us today in the
landscape
would that still apply in 2020 and are
we
broadly as a society doing everything we
should be doing to
foster that same environment that
brought you
yeah well i think u.s is still great
with respect to
innovation and fostering
entrepreneurship
so it's still great i think we don't
want to be complacent and we want to
say okay how can we make it better over
time
and i think we want to be um cautious
about the the gradual creep
of regulations and bureaucracy the
rules and regulations uh are immortal
and if we keep making more of a year and
do not uh do something about
uh removing them then eventually we will
be able to do nothing this is
very important and i think not well
appreciate this is just sort of like the
the
the slow boil of the frog you know his
part doesn't jump out because gets just
slightly hotter each year
um we should be aware of this i think
particularly at the state level
yeah well i want to talk about that
because uh you've been running into that
some in in california but
let me ask in a broader sense i mean
you've never been
i mean you've been working with
government you do business with
government now
uh you've expressed strong feelings
about government pro and con
at different times depending on the
circumstances but when you think through
an innovation lens in the broader
sense what's the right role for
government like what is the role
worship government be a player and where
should be hands off what's ideal in your
mind
sure um a lot of the time the best thing
that government can do is just get out
of the way
um and so that i'd say that that's the
default um probably best thing to do
then um after that would be ensuring
that uh there are not artificial
monopolies
that that there is
a federal ground for startups um
and the because what can happen over
time is they can get regulatory capture
by large companies
where they influence the regulators and
the legislators
to favor uh their
their situation and then you have a
forest of redwoods and you just can't
the the little uh
little trees can't grow so
we really want to have an environment
that that tends to favor uh smaller
companies and startups the big companies
really don't need the support
but they will they will generally try to
work the system to
establish a monopoly of some kind we
should be wary of that
um you know in general it's like
i i think we we could consider uh
changing
the way we think of things from
say capitalism versus communism i
apologize long answer but i think this
is
kind of um capitalism versus communism
and and think more in terms of feedback
loops so
is is a given organization does it give
an organization governor
or or a commercial have good feedback
loop for
the customer um whether it's the people
as a whole
or you know where whoever the customers
are and if you've got like
a duopoly or oligopoly they're generally
going to be have a weak
uh response to their customer um
and if they're monopoly they're going to
have the weakest response
to the customer and the reason that that
government i think
is often the worst at responding to
the customers being the people is that
they're a monopoly that can't go
bankrupt or usually cannot go bankrupt
so there's not there's not really a a a
cleansing process
for a government short of a catastrophe
um so i mean if you want to complain
about the dmv
what's the what's the alternative yeah
so
a couple things to unpack there first i
do want to when you talk about redwoods
dominating the
uh the air and smaller companies have a
challenge some people would hear that as
being
the situation in silicon valley today i
don't think that's what you replied but
is that what you see in silicon valley
today
well i think this is not a silicon
valley problem it's just
it's a general uh problem um i mean if
you look at say
you know how many how many candy
companies are there like you know big
candy is like
consolidated into like three companies
or something um and
they also own all the dog food and the
baby food so
it's like when's the last time there was
some good candy uh you know what's the
forcing function for
a new candy bar i haven't seen one in
ages um
so you know we gotta watch this like
consolidation
um that uh ends up resulting in
lower responsiveness to the end customer
and um
like i said it's like you can think of
like in the limit government is simply
the largest corporation yeah so some
people i think it's a false dichotomy
to look at government and sort of
industry as separate government is
simply
a corporation in the limit it is the
ultimate cooperation with the monopoly
so but then as you get closer to like
set up monopoly as
the feedback loop gets weaker and less
responsive to the customer
that's that's that's where you have
something which does not maximize the
happiness of people
which should be our objective overall
we had a couple of people last night at
this event uh who are joining the big
administration a couple of the
president-elect senior advisors
and clearly one of the things heavily on
their mind is sort of a new
national industrial policy for want of a
better term they talked about spending a
lot more on research and development
and fostering innovation big government
spending basically
um is is that kind of national
industrial policy a good idea is that a
good use of government
right now in your mind and if it is
where would you focus that kind of
effort
well it's governor's responsibility to
establish the rules of the game
and then to ensure that those rules are
properly enforced like
sort of like the the referees on the
field and you know it's like it's just
like
um you know football or something then
you've got the rules you've got the
referees you're gonna make sure the
rules are the right rules and the
referees are enforcing the rules
that's a that's an important role for
government uh to ensure that the rules
are correct
and that the incentives uh are what we
actually
want them to be for like i said the
long-term
maximum happiness of the people into the
future um
where i think government does not do a
great job is when they want to
not just be a referee on the field they
want to be a player on the field
uh this is not does not end up in a good
stage picking winners and losers that
kind of thing
i mean effectively government incentives
do
fake or do favor like you're gonna say
like what are the rules of the game
um i don't know this is obviously an
imperfect analogy but i
i do think it is a pretty good one um
that you you want the government to be
carefully focused on ensuring the rules
of the game are what we actually want
them to be
that we're getting rid of all rules this
is very important which is not occurring
um and that the the rules are
enforced such that we have uh ethical
behavior of companies um
yeah um now there are times when you
have an unpriced externality
such as the co2 capacity of the oceans
and atmosphere
so then if that is not priced in
effectively then you can get behavior in
industry behavior that does not that
that we think is
probably not good for the environment or
not good for
the future of the planet most of the
time
i mean provide pricing is correct you
will see
correct behavior from a private industry
um so you know that's like one example
where if we
effectively price carbon we'll see the
right behavior and then the government
does not need to try to pick
technology winners losers they can
simply incent the outcome i think it's
incredibly important
that government focus on incenting the
outcome not the path
um you mentioned california i have to
ask um
are you you're in texas right now and
there's been speculation and you've been
vocal this year on some of your
frustrations in california are you
really
are you relocating is it happening and
can you talk a little bit about
uh what's been troubling you in
california
uh so much this year since you since you
mentioned it
sure well first of all uh
tesla and spacex obviously have massive
operations in california in fact
it's worth noting that tesla is the last
car company still manufacturing cars in
california
uh spacex is the large the last
aerospace company
still doing significant manufacturing
california
so there used to be over a dozen car
plants in
california and california used to be the
center of aerospace manufacturing
my companies are the last two left
i want to emphasis so that's a very
important point to make
um for myself yes i i have moved to
texas
um we've got the starship development
uh here in south texas where i am right
now we're hopefully going to
do a launch later later today and then
we've got
a big factory development
just outside of austin for texas
but you made the move really but what
why why did you why did you go there is
that
is it all a personal decision or was it
it was partly a corporate
environment decision really for the
headquarters is that
well i mean in my case the two biggest
things that i've got going on right now
um are the starship development in south
texas
which was done this was set in motion
like five years ago um
and then the the the big new
uh u.s factory for for tesla which is
called gigatexas uh just by austin so
those are the two big projects
so these necessarily um drive the use of
my time
here um yeah and then the other big
thing
for uh tesla right now is the gig of
berlin so i was in berlin
i spent a fair amount of time in berlin
working on that um
and um yeah i think
there's you know there's um california
is great so
there's a lot of things that are really
great about california it's the biggest
economy in the country
most number of people um i do think
that uh that there's there is something
that happens when
um you know if it's
going into the sort of sports team
analogy like if a team has been winning
for too long
they they do tend to get a little
complacent a little entitled and then
they don't win the championship anymore
so california's been winning for a long
time um
and i think they're taking them for
granted a little bit yeah
let's talk a little more on innovation
in corporate america in general
i mean innovation has always been core
to who you are it's how you
think about your companies and your role
um
in the corporate suite in america are
our companies in general
uh fostering and developing and
innovation and
are the leaders in corporate america
you've got a lot of them on this call
or are we do we prioritize innovation as
much
as we might uh or need to do you think
right now
well i i think there's this this
innovation but then there's also just
um our um ceos in corporate america
focused enough on on product improvement
i think the answer is no um and i think
generally
my advice uh to or my recommendation
would really be
spend less time on on finance spend less
time in conference rooms
less time on powerpoint and more time
just trying to make your product as
amazing as possible
um and
particularly from that why why why why
is that is that because uh
boards or shareholders are
too financed and returned focused and
don't don't think enough about
product as being at the heart of of
value is because a certain kind of the
skill is cultivated um
why is that why why why is that a
problem in the c-suite
i think there might be too many mbas
running companies
um there's the mba isation of america
which i think is
maybe not that great um
there should be more focus on on the
product
the service itself less time on board
meetings
less time on on financials the
financials
come as a result like you say like
what's the point
of a company at all and why even have
companies
it's like a company's assembly of people
uh
gather together create a product or
service and deliver that product to
service
and sometimes people lose sight of that
a company has no value in and of itself
it only has value to the degree that is
effective allocator of resources to
create
goods and services that are of greater
value than the cost the inputs this
thing we call profit
is uh just just should just mean over
time that
the value of the output is is worth more
than the than the inputs
and and it's a reflection of the quality
of the product more than uh
so so the product is good presumably the
profits follow
rather than profits being called versus
problems and yeah
sometimes as people sort of have it
backwards and you know if people are
getting sort of
the incentive structure is coming from
the financial side of things
i don't i just i just honestly would
recommend
to anyone listening uh that
just spend less time in meeting rooms
less time on on on
powerpoint presentations less time in a
spreadsheet and more time
on the factory floor more time with
customers and obviously a lot of people
out there are already doing that but i
just like
i just urge people to say like hey step
back a second and say
is your product as awesome as it could
be probably not
um what could you do to make it make it
great um and
you know it's it's a it feel like think
about innovation like maybe it has to be
like breakthrough innovation i don't
think it necessarily has to be breaking
innovation it's just like
like you know just
make your product better it's this is
the thing that really matters
is that kind of product mindset that the
kind you describe
is that learnable is it is it teachable
or is there is there an innate element
that somebody has to have to really
to do it well i mean not everybody's
innovating or thinking
on your scale a lot but but
you you hi you look for innovative
people when you hire them is it
something that that is pretty easy
easily learnable or is there some
inequality in the people that uh
succeed i think it is learnable i mean
step number one would be try and any
have you tried and if have you tried
hard
and if you haven't tried hard try hard
i think it is learnable um
it's not some mysterious thing it's just
basically just be like
an absolute perfectionist about the
product that you make the service that's
provided um
seek negative feedback from all quarters
uh
you know from customers from from people
who aren't customers like hey
okay what can we make this how do we
make this better um
and you know i think that's it
it's absolutely learnable and and and
and just
if you find yourself spending a lot of
time
in getting presentations and reviewing
spreadsheets
you're blocking up the wrong tree
that's the that's the effect not the
cause
um so just get out there on the factory
floor
get out there in the stores talk to
customers
think about what what would what would
you love to have
oh and you know sometimes i think you
know and i've had this conversation that
tells a few times
where it's like we're trying to think
okay we don't
it's at times like we don't love this
product but we think others will love it
you know that's not really how it works
if you don't love it don't expect others
will either
[Music]
now you're at a moment i want to talk
about your companies in a minute but
you're at a moment where both we're
particularly tesla and spacex are really
growing in lots of ways right now
um and you've had plenty of ups and
downs even at this point but but
but it's a high point on your own
journey in this way
what are the biggest mistakes you've
made that you've learned from
because you talked a little bit about
being willing to put yourself out there
fail learn keep growing what were
turning points for you
that really you you you said wait a
minute this is wrong or this is the
wrong move either personally or or for
the company
and that that you learn from that have
fed to where you are right now
well if i had to list all the mistakes
this would be a very long call
um so it's too too much to even think of
i'm trying to think like
how could i could i classify them in
some way
um
well i mean some of the things i
mentioned just before it's like
where you know i was recommending that
people spend less time in a conference
room less time getting presentations and
and spreadsheets and that like generally
that's like when when i have
spent too much time in a conference room
that's generally when things have gone
awry and when i go and spend time on the
factory floor
um or you know really using the
the cars um thinking about the rockets
it's like
that's where things have gone gone
better um but does that does that risk
some some people would worry that that
risk sending a message to
your your teams that you personally have
to be involved for something to work
that you can't delegate or you can't
trust them i think that's one thing that
makes some
[Music]
executives reluctant they're trying to
find that line between showing their
personal commitment
and trusting their subordinates to do
the work so
yeah i mean you're known for being
passionate sleeping on the factory floor
but but but is that a concern for you or
do you not care does this
that's not an issue for you how do you
think about it
well there's a lot of talented people at
spacex and tesla
um and i think the morale is
is good um uh i
for sure respect them greatly and it's
an honor to work with them
um and i find that if if i am um
engrossing the details of the issues
this does not result in them feeling
better but
worse but feeling better like my
experience more energized
um you know it's like
you know you think about like war
it's like do you want the general in
some like
you know ivory tower or or on the front
lines
like troops gonna the troops are gonna
fight a lot harder
if they see the general on the front
lines than if they think generals you
know
in some cushy situation so
it's like
nobody bleeds the prince in the palace
get out there on the goddamn front line
and and you know show them that you care
and that
you're not just in some plush office
somewhere
um yeah i mean my plush office right now
actually yeah
yeah well yeah um let's talk quickly
about tesla
um but both tesla and spacex were
scaling up today in fact i mean tesla
touched 600 billion i think yesterday in
evaluation today you said you're going
to raise 5 billion to do stock sales
um i assume and i assume what those
gains are really in your mind going to
do is help you scale up faster
be poured back into investment because
now is the moment to do that is that the
plan here
yeah i mean i i guess there's
um you know what
we're kind of debating like should we
raise money or should we not um
it wasn't like a 100 sure thing um
in the end we thought well we can retire
a lot of the debt and
increase the security of the company
well probably a good thing
uh and for less than one percent of
solutions probably makes sense
um but we're you know neither here here
or there on that i think it's a
it could have gone either way so what is
so the money is for really debt
retirement you're saying today
uh debt retirement and like i guess to
have a
bit more of a war chest or you know um
you know what what is money money is an
entry in a database
okay i want to think a couple questions
uh from the audience first i want to go
to a video question
uh that we solicited um uh if we could
play that
um hello my name is catherine parsons
and i'm the ceo of technology education
company decoded
i want to know are machines able to
innovate
or is innovation an inherently human
capability
yeah i think uh machines will well my
views on ai
uh i've spoken a lot about this hey i
will be able to do everything
better than human over time everything
everything includes yeah okay uh elon
here's one
um uh if you could have a very quick
very quick easy one if you could redo
the entire transportation infrastructure
of the united states
how would it look michael fountain asks
the entire
transportation infrastructure wow um
the main thing that i see missing here
is uh
that we need to go 3d in cities in order
to alleviate traffic congestion
and um i think probably the best way to
do that
is with uh with tunnels um it sounds it
may sound a bit silly but
boring company that you you started
which looks at that now
yeah in fact for for many years i was
asked what do i see as the biggest
opportunity
for new companies and i kept saying can
someone please build tunnels
for half a decade i said this and nobody
built tunnels so it's like fine we'll
start a company and start building some
tunnels and we've got the first tunnel
that's uh going to be opening up
first commercial tunnel opening up in
vegas uh going from the convention
center to the strip
and i think who will have an opportunity
to try it out and be able to see that
hey if we just go 3d and cities we don't
have to be stuck in gridlock those are
great
and so i'd recommend tunnels and then
for long distance travel
the you can do
tunnels or tubes but if you evacuate the
tunnel and
and essentially remove the air or most
of the air you can you can get rid of
the uh air friction and you can go uh
supersonic
uh and do so with
i mean with no um dependence on weather
and with no need to get to high altitude
or create any sonic boom issues so
that's what i meant by sort of a
hyperloop it in it's just basically
a pressurized electric car
in a vacuum tube um so i think this
this will be our evolution in transport
that would be amazing
um and um
hopefully others do it not just the
boring company okay here's one
uh elon i'm a founder of a founder and
ceo of a private company in the battle
one of the changes i'm seeing uh is
people trying to force
uh the company uh on political and
social matters
uh you know making demands not to sell
police or not to sell the government
agencies there's walkouts and protests
google do you think this kind of thing
is having a chilling effect or will have
a chilling effect on innovation
well a lot of this stuff is is centered
in the san francisco bay area
and i think there's the the silicon
valley of the san francisco bay area has
too much influence on the world in my
opinion and i say that as someone who
has spent most of his life in california
mostly in the bay area
so you're like you're like your friend
peter thiel
feels it's gotten more stifling up there
you you that you're expressing
you agree with me yes i think there's
uh the the bay area has
outsized influence in the world uh so
is that changing is the pandemic
changing that i mean is there a real
chance here that with
departures and people leaving the valley
that we're going to see some of that
scatter
out into the country side for good now
uh post pandemic
i think we'll see some reduction in the
influence of silicon valley
um but the social media is still very
much centered in silicon valley
so i think we need to be concerned about
mind viruses
just you know memes that
travel very quickly through social media
that may or may not be correct um
and we certainly want to encourage a
healthy dialogue
uh so you know there's some out there
who just want to shut down
one side of a debate or another i think
we should
resist that yeah we're out of time
unfortunately because i could go for an
hour we didn't even get to half of the
questions i had but thank you for the
time today it's good to see you
uh and hope we can continue the
conversation another time and
it's always fascinating to hear what's
on your mind so thanks and and good luck
on your projects right now
all right thank you thank you elon